what is up putting people and welcome to
the honest trailer commentaries live for
the MCU I believe it is our 300th
episode spectacular yeah except for
endgame except for nd except for a game
I'm Spencer Gilbert Joestar that's gonna
say damn no god no you're not dan lon
dan either first time appearing in front
of camera the editor of honest trailers
Kevin
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah thank you so much for joining us
you are thanks for having me you're Dan
number two dan started as the editor I
won't say moved on to bigger and better
things cuz you're doing the biggest and
best things of all which is turning our
Morris script and notes into a
digestible three to seven minute little
weekly web series yeah yeah I definitely
you guys just hand me the script and I
just have to try to bring it to life as
best I can in time coming in relatively
recently and seeing the whole process I
think a lot of people myself included
assume that it's a writer's kind of
medium honest trailers but now it's
another issue it really is an editor's
thing when you see it all put together
like the jokes are one thing but they
come together in how it's all sort of
assembled yeah
yeah yeah you guys just you guys give me
the blueprint now I just tried to write
you know just over the city exactly
you're making it happen for those of you
who haven't watched before hello we will
have some deleted scenes and there's a
bunch oh yeah at the end of this one and
also because it's our 300th we're doing
some like fan overarching series
questions we're taking your questions I
got some that I like praying out here
but the fire mouth from the chat I will
they'll scroll right by I won't pay
attention to them but maybe I'll scroll
back and pick a few out at the end you
know guys we're talking the MCU the 300
songs trailer we decided to just do all
the things at once we typically tend to
bite off more than we can jus for not
worth it rewards because we could have
just done 300 rise of an empire and
called today yeah I do this cuz we're
conditioning ourselves Spencer yeah just
as I believe the tale is honest trailers
was once every other week oh it was
whenever like there was what ever would
- and then defi pre-fall in there is
like with one summer we'd like to do it
weekly just for fun
and then came weekly but now we used to
do we'll do a show or big every now and
then and we used to do like super cuts
instead honest trailers like that was a
next week off now we've conditioned
ourselves I think because of like Doctor
Who and yeah Thrones and we're just like
yeah now let's do more yeah I mean we've
expanded like Danielle and I sort of
came on board to house our thing now
that there's more people that's true we
can get a little ambitious in terms of
like let's divvy up you can do these
three and these four yeah so I mean I
think maybe but we've we've
overcompensated by now making it much
even harder you know it sounds like a
good idea
a month ago like there's fun things we
haven't said about the individual Marvel
movies let's do all the Marvel movies
yeah whenever you guys whenever I see it
on the schedule like I see something
like in time to you franchise something
the Tim Burton one Dan did start to have
buyer's remorse yeah I the end
Malenko with going every temporary last
three or four always took that one to
the face yeah we I was only trying to
help a bunch of Tim Burton movie send
notes but no that was 90% of that one
was just sorry but I was working on
mortal engines everyone was clamoring
for that what if the cities were they
mortal who's to say and Peter Jackson
personally tried to explain it to me
what makes the engines mortal humblebrag
yeah yeah yeah I know Peter Jack's
aren't we all at the end of the day I'm
sure we're gonna have a ton to say and I
want to save some room for fan questions
at the end so let's just dive into the
MCU honest trailer pause when you have
something to say let's go
as people six years ago asked you for
Ironman tale my first Australian I'm
into oh well no Harry Potter Hopi yep in
a world where a bankrupt comic book
company sold the film rights to its best
characters for peanuts because they
thought movies would be a good way to
show more comics the history of the MCU
is kind of fascinating to me because
Marvel was super bankrupt in the 90s and
the people behind it everyone's favorite
Ike Perlmutter sure it wasn't again it
wasn't just to sell commerce because
that wasn't where the profits were it
was toys
it was merchandising merchandising
recognizing much like yogurt from
Spaceballs where the real money for the
movie was made yeah and veinous the
flamethrower the reason the reason we
got Iron Man first even though like
Captain America seemed like they're the
centerpiece of what they got because it
was like Captain America Hulk Thor Iron
Man Nick Fury I think yeah the original
MCU characters is I did some focus
groups and put toys of all of the
characters they had the rights of in
front of them and kids were like so
that's why Iron Man was the first one to
go into development no idea yeah it's
funny if you go back to that original
article like variety wrote about like
well there's a Marvel and paramount are
gonna team up and make some movies
because these little characters they'd
like they were explaining who these
characters are cuz they assume most
Americans don't know though like he's
like Nick Fury he's basically Marvel's
version of James Bond that's like a
world where yeah people didn't know who
Nick Fury was and me it meant nothing
yeah that's great funny thing I feel
like if you put Nick Fury versus Hydra
toys in front of people they'd be like
well this is just GI Joe's which is
broken because when GI Joes was a line
Hasbro was like Marvel make this a story
and they basically use Howling Commandos
and hydras and turn it into GI Joe and
Cobra so they they shot Fury I pretty
sure I just said something possibly very
low rung on live TV pretty sure that's
correct
yeah we're flying without a wire here
live unlike the show usually where
there's lots of rehearsal and our CEO
goes through and censors the whole thing
yeah hostile takeover cue the pyro damn
it you missed your killing executive
when he can with the rejects that no one
wanted and do so well they get bought
out by Disney before it was cool
cinematic human company owns everything
except Ray
welcome to the MCU a TV series made of
movies about comic books where magic is
actually science your ancestors called
it magic and you call it science but not
by magic by technology magic science
there's a lot more typical MCU
protagonist a loner with no pets no
biological siblings and whose only
friends are their co-workers pause you
know people could bring up fairly you
know Black Panther he has a biological
sibling he's the exception that proves
the rule I say yep he's not gonna leave
like a pattern of the moon you can't
really deny that they're they're loners
they don't have family around them they
have like one friend like that's that's
yes black sort of a little bit of an
exception yeah mom no freak is not I'm
pretty sure I don't think they directly
deal with this in the movie those
parents could have the two of them could
have produced hella I'm pretty sure yeah
I've read that they are half siblings so
but I would also argue that like I know
they're siblings it's not like there's
an interesting relationship or anything
like there because we get into it later
too but you know with like all the weird
like sexless romance and stuff when you
start to really strip it down and it's
like I am person man and I have
co-worker friends and I am alone and we
kissed
yeah these movies have they have to
service so much and like introduces
characters in so much plot like giving
them more than one friend like why kind
of late in the series it really lays it
out it's like it's it's efficiency it's
just the love of you know like you've
got a certain amount of time so it's
like well he just got into jail so he
has a cellmate who's his friend he's got
this one woman who he's sort of interact
with he's got this one job to do but
it's like yeah movies over yep we're
saying they all need at least one
rom-com basketball-playing pal is what
we're saying they do yeah have your
Philip Seymour Hoffman pratfalls all
right keep going whose personality can
range from light-hearted quip stir is
closed today to stern duty-bound
military type you get hurt or them back
get killed walk it off and on a long
enough time line everyone do you Marvel
character type space follow along their
hero's journeys we're after a motivating
Uncle Ben's situation they'll get a
transformational hairstyle cut some
cards and find the strength to bow they
say their superhero name out loud now
pause the that Uncle Ben grid I think
that it goes by so fast but it did shock
me how many motivating mentor deaths
there are like I could have told you
that's a trope but really every single
hero somebody they look up to dies very
early on in their superhero career I
think some of that you do have to put
and not to a great great guy legend icon
but some of that does go back to like
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby like these these
stories had formats in their original
version so much they can't change every
litter of name lament or frozen mad we
invest them with so much important to me
people are spending you know weeks on
these fandom pages like TWiki updating
making it all like so perfect as they
should
as they should not discouraging you but
Kirby and Ditko and we were like
scrawling that on an afternoon yeah like
they they weren't treating them as
sacred you know we had like every animal
like physical element of every race
that's like mix-match it was the it was
the early version of the Twitter meme
where you finish sentences with an
autocorrect yeah yeah they were making
character character it is like a
stickman and he throws sticks
yeah stick to run his leg still man yeah
now we're cooking anyways keep going I
am Iron Man and Thor son of Odin a man
I'm Nick Fury
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange and
weirdly there's a hunter character nah
man never say don't even that we all
refer to them as you know your Scarlet
Witch or whatever who what people sick
Marvel good as their villain and thank
god that's not true or the MCU would be
hot garbage thrill as they spare 10
minutes to establish a bad guy who's
just like the hero but evil of faceless
horde can feel bad if it doesn't have a
face oh actually a pretty awesome
character and they're dead but everyone
knows the MCU talked about his dad's he
was cold he was calculating you know
where this was a good realization
trailer good I will tear him apart the
the chat has pointed out that motivating
deaths is a Joseph Campbell thing so
congratulations you read hero with a
thousand faces have a stark well I read
hero a thousand one places
meticulously planned story told across
23 separate movies all about Thanos
killing have the universe
well first he has to get an Infinity
Gauntlet no not that God yeah yeah that
one and then gathered the Infinity
stones
well yeah promise again so I think in
looking into this like this was Joss
Whedon just thought it'd be like cool
like it's amazing looking back how much
this was kind of ad hoc and like in the
moment that they were just kind of
pulling out of there but that he's like
this would be like a fun only comic
people know about tears what's that the
gun gauntlet and then just Stannis in
general of like putting him at the end
of was it a vendor even the original
engine yeah and then it's like they at
that point there was no superstructure
story to it it was just like a little
dangle or someone else could pick it up
and run with it if they want they're
definitely still kind of like even with
the first Avengers movie it was still
kinda like we don't really know this is
gonna work yet and so yeah they put that
in there and then because that was that
the last paramount or was that yeah
believe so okay a benders yeah cuz then
it does feel like then Disney was like
so what's this purple guy thing all
about you guys got a plan in there
people responded only to the Avengers
they must have been like okay yeah we
gotta keep doing this they love this new
yeah but you can't tell that suddenly
they have to like come up with a much
larger overarching structure than they'd
originally planned I think a lot of
people assume that a better story would
be if you sat down for like a week and
like plot it out 500 movies but a lot of
time you you do kind of have to find the
story in a Tele right at least give the
impression that you're letting your
creators own their own movies right I
have something because when you don't
you end up with like I think the weakest
ones are like Iron Man 2
age of Ultron where it does feel like
it's trying to service like a TV series
plot line and like further along all
these other plot lines rather than tell
its own story yeah I agree
Ultron especially feels like it's just
like well we got introduced
we gotta introduce you know the maksimov
we got all you know it's a lot of like
table setting before you get to the
movie now that's a deleted scene alright
let's keep going then gather the
Infinity stones well send proxies to get
them and it gives one away but
eventually you'll get the stones some
are stones while the other relics often
appears he also changes color about
different shades of purple after the
universe which also doesn't make much
sense
oh also the timeline doesn't work out
that was a real unforced error it wasn't
so play electro just don't play years
later no phase the boundary-pushing
experimental phase and if Rob dogs have
taught me anything
phase four will have the MCU puking in
the gutter wondering where it all went
wrong journey is a fighting City to the
wonders of Earth I think Paz that the
Viking space joke kind of gets lost
because it's like I think Thor gets to
the the Asgardians got to name like the
nine realms yes I guess the Vikings got
there first so everything is like far
time yeah every planet in the MCU is
like some Old Norse like there's no like
Pluto like Chinese I don't have a deep
connection to King Louie because I grew
up in Louisville but like someone got
there and they were like we're naming
this after all all spaces Viking space
now I think if we treated if the MCU
spent more time with like on the street
level with with people there would be a
real resurgence of like paganism and
like Viking religious belief because
they were right they nailed it all along
was Thor real Odin got a flounder of a
small book about I did a very long piece
for fandom about
about this very thing like talking to
religious leaders are like what impact
do you think this series would have on
did you talk about liking them I did not
talk to a real light they're a little
but they're very busy pillaging in their
long homes yeah all these in a long boat
is pillaging something but know that I
think one interesting thing is that you
know in the in the reality of these
movies the idea is like well Thor was
never a god he was always an alien
called gods we actually called a strong
Australian man Easter and these dumb
Vikings being stupid and not scientific
assumed he must be the god of a nerd but
he calls himself that at some point does
you know no he will look as though thor
ragnarok is he's got a thunder and that
neither keeps on lord of threat but no
so i think that idea is a call to up
again yeah yeah if you accept that that
then doesn't that kind of ruin every
world religion because it's like what
wasn't every religious figure and god
just an alien that like you know how
could you believe anything it also gets
to be a weird slippery slope because
it's like does this mean the ancient
aliens guy was right no definitely like
yeah i mean in the in me was everything
just aliens coming down and see you yes
when they come out with the Eternals
like the angelina jolie is gonna build
the pyramids and like it'll all be yeah
it's all there man who is all apocalypse
even serve yeah gotta be great thank you
go turn it dimensions to the wonders of
earth oops that one Zootopia and
everything still kind of looks and feels
the same as visionary indie filmmakers
are fun I think several digital but
everything is CGI every story there's a
pool of sexless romance yeah I never
take so why not just add some color
that's what it was yeah for a series
with so many physically perfect people
this is like just not a sexy why don't
they all have on screen for us it's like
I don't know there's just something we
it's like that was busy the world very
busy
su-mei pork on their own time like yeah
you know that's the the these movies
would be really weird if they had a
sexually in the would they if Scott
Schneider derp era of Zack Snyder
directed a man it's like the implication
is like he won he's not asexual or
sexless like at one time he had a
relationship with Rachel McAdams who I
don't I had a girlfriend she where her
name was Christian from the Niagara
Falls area Canada you can't see her we
dated over spring break very busy with
her successful nursing career / being a
model in like a sexless period of their
lives you know they've entered this time
where they're just focusing on super
here always an omission yeah which is
fine but they're like just really owns -
compelling like romance is like Steven
Bucky or Steven Peggy that's weird she
worked for him like I rewatched like
that
yeah glossed right over that but like
he's like will you get me this give me
that I'm gonna sand let's make up yeah
and the first one especially there's a
lot of like no mr. stark I work for you
and that would not be appropriate which
by two and three is just like that all
right keep coming violence
have you heard of a band called the
bubbly soundtrack is annoying
yes we've reached the point where we're
so old that this stuff is new again but
the bump will be soundtrack to me is
just like now that's what I call the
1980s I went to the Wikipedia page for
the year the movie set and just picked
like a of the top 20 so I know they're
good songs I heard them on the radio
every effing day in carpool these are
not deep cuts if you're finding it's
like if today well I don't know who's
popular today Ryan in 20 years when you
see some like nostalgia milking movie
and it's just like like seven ariana
grande like lil yachty Beyonce songs and
aroni all dj khaled it's like this guy
was the best music in 2018 anyways music
supervisors there they listen to him
when a movie does a really good job of
matching the on-screen action to the
song it's so delightful that you wish
that there like every needle drop should
be like that if you're gonna do one
don't just do them just to do them like
tomorrow as you said just a girl in
captain bar was a great example of like
the music fits the moment it's the right
vibe for when it happened exactly Who am
I personal flying monkeys I understood
that Harry Potter oops that's pixels for
an interconnected movie verse that had a
1 in 14 million 605 shot of working but
those odds didn't stop every other
studio from awkwardly mashing their IPS
together like a junior high dance floor
leaning marble as the only one standing
in a dying industry we do disorder but
launching a whole new industry a Marvel
movie news Thank You Marvin analysis
channels
and comedy web series that would have
died a long time ago if Marvel movies
weren't so popular so one way or another
in the end
everyone's getting paid by Disney you
shills no one company runs the opinions
of any reactor on the planet quantum
phase where an object moves through
different states of matter and
einstein-rosen bridge it's a theoretical
connection between two different points
of space the quantum system would revert
back to separate experiment I guess we
didn't include Peter Parker in this
Parker there's like other geniuses that
we didn't even get to get out of
airplanes do this one that is a
spaceship
[Music]
couple helicopters oh thank you thank
you
losers we should have done a whole
rainbow spectrum like yeah Boise bib
yeah this was a revelation for me I knew
this was like black widows go to
everyone I realize how many characters
did the leg says there it is well the
Train work people like that UFC pulling
up in an Audi pause in I think it said
game when he pulls up to avengers
headquarters in an Audi it's an electric
car but nobody I guess they didn't think
anyone would like think it's cool if it
didn't make a lot of noise so they piped
in engineer said he's going around so
how D calls the shots yeah they seem
like nice car you would be driving
something like concept car there's like
a stark mobile you know off the lot like
last weekend he went to the Audi
dealership yeah big deal at this point
Tony Stark has like like pumps shoes
where he's like Shh and like a car grows
out of his basement for an hour for like
like the Wonder Twins or the guy turns
into a car I'm just going to type turns
into water stuff and the other turns
into animals right here it is this is a
good content River yeah my reaction when
I turn into a car form of car post this
later for you
for the healthy gift of a man turning
into a bar you just did a reaction video
Spencer yes to wear twin things I Google
of the the chat meanwhile has been
happening this whole time I imagine I
should have been checking hmm all right
well let's continue ignoring that keep
going
dick measuring I'm having the gun you
are not the big gun Tony don't be jel no
everytime raging fire smoldering for my
record 21 feet not bad you 65 weird non
Stan Lee cameo grumps did you know I was
in commentating is nickel so alright
pause this one's on me
there's a lot of I see the top comment
is is why didn't you put Yahoo's arrow
in their guardians one was my film I
slip through the cracks
actually I thought of it at one point
but well it's Kevin's fault as we
actually as I was putting those together
I I didn't think of it then I thought
that like later on as I'd moved past it
and that was like oh I got remember that
so I could toss it back in there and
I'll also take I put integrate when I
first suggested multi hit combos I did
make a little note there of some of the
other movies that I knew they were in so
this is like a I'm not sure I included
yeah sure yeah here's what I'll say
pointing out the thing does not mean we
include all of them because in the video
is a lifeless 45-minute shapeless
formless thing and but Joe the good some
I'm not saying at a supercut sometimes
the comments are right very rarely in
this one in an instance they are correct
we totally dropped the ball on yondu's
arrow because this whole thing is like
it hits a lot of people at once
yeah all he has to do is whistle just
whistle just knows I drew an arrow I
just want it done
can you sketch your deal too as that
anyways keep going this was actually the
shot that made me think of mafia combos
with the ancient ones yeah she just like
Chuck's her discs around
are you sure you know how to fly this
thing you do not apply this thing ah
you'll see use anything how to fly this
thing I said how hard could it be
take the wheel no I don't know she's
running a PhD and never pets a crate
Guardians 1 they're sitting in storage
that was the biggest thing that stood
out do I want to talk about the saga of
Star Wars Star Lords just rewatching it
like that was like it
whoa that got my attention line like
they snuck in a gist joke in in it
you
okay we were just talking about
star-lord is before the innocent went
down come on Matt let's keep going yeah
although side note JT we cannot see the
honest trailer anymore on the screen I
assume you will take care of that while
we continue her talk of stuff of famous
it's all purple so we're inside this but
and they would see moments before
expanding the universe I wish that
happened that was the that was the big
standout moment and you guys could maybe
share yours on rewatching what we
divvied it up but a lot of the MCU
movies it was um that line about saying
that if you trying to black light in
here it'd be like a Jackson Pollock
painting because that is disgusting and
they are all sitting in there's been
yeah he's quill Jack elating everywhere
because at first we were like do we
start showing everyone who's ever sat in
a guardianship but then it was like
remember at the end they built a new one
too but can we assume that he treats all
of his ships like this I'm hoping he's
gonna be more respectful of the benitar
because when he had the mallanna he was
alone he was losing through the galaxy
by himself now he knows he's got a team
Andre I just realized when I went back
in for that joke it was what were you
watching that scene if you listen
closely to that conversation where he's
trying to give this big speech and stuff
you can actually hear a couple like and
just there's this quiet no I'm saying he
takes a little step in just a squishy
sound no that's too far he's gonna say
like we should add that as a hilarious
joke guys one step ahead of you watch a
scene of his and his big important
speech to try and get them back to you
guys he should have been fired geez
the other thing that stood out on my
real means watch was what was it oh that
in the Avengers when Iron Man comes in
to save the day from Loki in that like
plaza in in Germany he's playing ac/dc
like out of speakers like this isn't
just
soundtrack ac/dc yeah
somebody the this like Holocaust
survivor just like stood up to Loki like
never again I just can't believe that
like read the room Tony Stark my big
takeaway was Ultron was one of mine and
I was like I think we gave age of Ultron
a bad rap and then you were like did you
watch it all the way through it I was
like no I've been watching it in 20
minute blocks and you were like there
you go yeah it is a film of of 20 minute
blocks yes yeah anything big on your
your rewatching one of the movies I had
was as I mentioned sort of Doctor
Strange and it really it really does tie
in me like the loner hero like he's so
they're just there's no sense that
Stephen strange has any kind of life in
the movie at the beginning he's like we
saw that shot of him like alone in his
apartment with the rain it's like it's
so isolating and you really do feel for
the guy it's like he is sort of the
prototypical like M scene here like he
has to become a superhero is the only
thing that will give his life meaning
mmm yeah he's just got he's got nothing
you know like he doesn't have a dog he
doesn't seem to enjoy his work he
doesn't have a hobby nope just like man
like thank God there was mad I think
surgeons are notoriously sociopaths
that's true I think you're kind of crazy
people yeah he's got a very nice drawer
full of watches
so very Nigel Oscar I guess he's poured
all of himself into that watch drawer
yeah Kevin anything big on your on your
not that good they can earn everything
see you okay no I also really watched
the first Ironman on mine which is
interesting to go all the way back to
the beginning yes we were talking a
little bit about it's it's it's like
inset in our real world it was like the
only one they really tried to do that
with yeah it started that way right cuz
that what about sort of Iraq and
Afghanistan and the Middle East and
weapons and the military-industrial
complex and the others all they have
themes and ideas but they're not like
plugged into the politics of the yeah
yeah well I mean I guess the politics of
the day would shift once aliens start
coming out of the sky you're doing 20 of
these and it's become the hugest
franchise in the world that doesn't
necessarily make as much anything they
do try to put in like are you saying
that early on they were putting politics
into their movies Ilan I'm saying things
out of my films about genetically
engineered soldiers of war is so tired
is all I'm trying to say is that Kevin
Feige is a SOI boy oh boy
I've got soy right here looking at a soy
face alright let's keep going oh those
do gives me strange the neverending
story man we forgot to say anything
about the ABC shows Netflix series one
shots and spin-offs yeah sodium doesn't
matter I'm not gonna watch it you can't
make us cuz we have so much delayed
scenes let's go right in let's keep
going screw you cloak and dagger we
prepped America
and if Rock Doc's have taught me
anything it's that you'll stay on top
forever only up from here and if not
Ducks have taught me anything phase four
will have the MCU develop a serious drug
habit and get really into jazz fusion Oh
every story is full of sexless romance
that never takes off I think it was
you guys only people get two seals
fighting over a job you've dropped on
mm-hmm
yes just after a romantic moment you
think you can stop daydreaming about my
daughter long enough to get my life its
paws paws is it weird that they in the
same way that they do the thing where
they comment on the weirdness there's a
wizard and a spider do the same thing
with romance that's weird
yeah you can't like they treat like
we're chasing a squid alien with a
wizard and and Olympians yeah and then
they treat the same thing with like you
just kissed a person on the mouth
romantic like adults feeling awkward
about liking one another and it's like
not so much you know where's like 30
year-olds like oh like billionaires
model athletes wives and stuff like that
like they've all done it shy about
kissing a girl in front of their friend
anyway so let's keep going oh dude that
may be drag standing there an hour an
hour
bloodless violence that never leaves
more than a couple of foreheads great
almost foreheads are so many for
histogram like that for a drop of blood
and toothless comedy that thinks
describing what's happening is the peak
of humor it sounds like you had a pretty
special and intimate relationship with
this hammer and then losing that was
almost comparable yeah this Brian almost
takes it out of context like these are
all supposed to be playing as jokes in
the movies man and the very laws of
physics tried very hard to kill me but I
left him chained up in Greenwich Village
and the quickest way back there is
through a dimensional gateway that the
DNA we've been hired to stop an
interdimensional vision feeding on those
batteries and I was like these are weird
movies if we just say it as a joke with
no attempt
half sister be imprisoned in hell but
she returned home and stopped me in the
eye so that's a good way to remind me I
mean what none of this makes sense
starring evil CEOs table setting you go
this was exposition scene set at a table
he's my brother
he killed 80 people in two days he's
adopted thanks to you those insidious
shapeshifters will threaten our borders
no more at least Vanden are sitting at
the table beggin no longer be a private
organization we've got to get to the
core before he does mmm I like so many
car fights you you know a car for
children is the heroic slow-mo flip over
cars moving car to go kick-ass on
another car like that's that's where I
was thinking we could go in like like I
was in this car I'm gonna jump on the
idea was to carry another exposition to
my city people the tesseract could be
the key to unlimited sustainable that'll
be 1 million dollars please how so we
needed a quantum surge and threatened
Alice Howard said the arc reactor was
the stepping stone to something greater
we learned that not only nobody was
really happy they have to Marvel Gables
ever do besides walk into a room and
caverns they're just like eyes just like
them doing mundane things you don't see
this from DC cool
at one time yeah yeah yes it's very
people fanning out I sort of met your
knee
I watched you while you were sleeping
Disney cinematic revenue area when
Stanley met foggy nights wrong else
that's all yeah well you know I don't
know I don't think much of value was
lost just car fights maybe car fights
yeah car fight fun color fights well I
think well let's launch into the fan
question because there's a relevant one
that I liked that Kevin can help on how
did you break up the workload on this
one did we watch some assign movies and
compare notes or didn't one of us take
point while the rest watched a few like
the Tim Burton trailer curious to how to
know how you chose the tropes to call
out thank you this was at forensic chick
the workload for us is pretty simple we
did just get all of us in room talk out
like because we've all seen all the
Marvel movies the things we kind of
recognized and knew that would be there
but as it was happening we started
adding things to a shared Google Doc of
like well it turns out that everyone's
got a dad problem right so as we all
watched our respective movies we added
more and more to that list I'm curious
how do you handle an editing task of 22
films at once well I did have some extra
time in the coming weeks so uh when I
did see the when the trope list on the
Google Doc was made I was as it was
being updated I would have movie by
movie and I would just simply just go
through and just try to quickly grab
them and create all these different
string outs that would include every
single trip that you guys were listening
and
pretty much just had to go through every
movie one by one but I didn't have to
watch him think I just had you guys put
the time codes and everything I just had
to quickly grow and grab it and stick a
Bert should have been so yeah
well than that um and then once the yeah
all the trips are made uh you know I get
the script from you guys and well
usually in the beginning like for the
usual honest trailer like on you guys we
put them up on Tuesdays you guys are
writing them you should by that time for
the next one and then I get the you know
I kinda know what movies to be made I
tried to watch it I go through and build
a string out of shots usually I tried to
find shots for like the starring section
of all the character shots and stoic
shots where they're not laying
flip-flopping hmm do you like go through
and look for because you're really good
at pulling shots that sell jokes or sell
mood or sell ideas like you guys ruin
your life here's a good I roll shot and
that'll probably be a John commenting on
something yeah when I'm will going
through through the movie I definitely
am looking for the character shots in
them also have a separate string out
that call reactions mm-hmm and that's
just looking for the I roles the high
fives people frustrated anything that
was funny whatever at the moment and
that's part of what I'm saying like it
seems when you're watching on his
trailer you're thinking about the
writing and the dialogue and the jokes
but so much of the comedy is that stuff
it's like having the music cut out at
the right moment to sell the lie on
their length
yeah finding the exact right moment of
Thanos making the right expression and
like that's where the next time you guys
out there watching it out stray like pay
attention to that stuff and you'll see
like it elevates it so much yeah yeah
that's just not to not the genius work
we're doing I've also learned over the
past couple years I've been here editing
yeah you know wasn't like that at least
in the beginning I had some trouble with
music especially but now it's kind of
like I kinda know the rhythm I know yeah
there's a learning process which leads
us to this fan question at Julie dykes
has your creative slash writing process
evolved over time and has there been any
particular input or event that made you
reassess how you
about it I don't know you guys are a new
issue Jolla so lon like yeah big
learning curve for me I tell you was to
not and this is not a knock on those
guys god bless him but to not do
cinemasins because I my initial thinking
when I first started doing this was we
watch a movie and I would just take
notes on everything stupid and that's
not that helpful it's you got to be
looking for the threads pull through the
whole movie because that's what you're
gonna like pull out of them to make the
joke I would agree for me it's always a
struggle because we are when we write
these we're coming fresh off of like one
two if not three very close REE
watchings of the film so like I can tell
you every single thing about the plot of
the movie that is coming up this next
week which is gonna be a wet one I can
tell you everything about but the people
who watch this movie probably remember
none of that they remember just like
basic compressions and that's our
audience or that's why I feel like we're
writing to is the person who saw the
movie in theaters and hadn't really
thought about it until the honest
trailer came out like so we are not
going to point out like oh well he looks
left but clearly the bad guy is going
off to his right because they don't
remember that that's that's not that's
not their honest impression of the movie
it also it seems like such a dumb thing
to try to remember but it is a trailer
yes it's like a parody of a trip I
forget that all the time because I do
the same thing where I'm like I remember
when I first started you used to like
look over at my laptop and you could
just see like John I don't draft up and
you would just be like too long too long
too many ways you would just see like
here's this s a block of text just be
like nope yeah yeah you can just look
from a distance and be like that's not
gonna sound like a trailer and granted
trailers don't sound like this anymore
this is a very specific era of 1980 to
1995 where they would have one of these
like guy LaFontaine or whatever do like
in a world
bla bla bla bla bla bla that's nine
words right there like we're making
jokes nine words at a time mm-hmm so
that's I think that's how it's evolved
Butler what's everyone's favorite honest
trailer asked legato
20:57 and I will now read the chat for
some other questions so you guys talk Oh
what are some good ones probably my
favorites
definitely the West Anderson everyone
yeah that one is good I think we did
about that Oh cross the board just
nailed it on the writing and a and and
our voice every guy that we brought in
as well yeah I like anyone where we get
to do something kind of weird and
different I loved having the the ASL guy
for quiet place I thought that was
really I thought that was really funny
it was just a weird challenge to with
like I didn't understand how you
translate any of that so he's like no I
literally have to like translate your
sounds and ideas
scrolling back through the comments Rob
Turner asked why do people assume feyo's
has a normal booty he could have four
butts full of acid for all you know
that's completely fair that's completely
fair I'm gonna take a little issue with
that we know the Thanos eats we've seen
him cooking for himself very
conventional he's putting spices he's
stirring a pot so he's got to have a
relatively conventional digestive tract
why would he have butts full of acid
well he might have a different you know
unless he's putting food in his butt to
digest it that wouldn't make sense okay
fair enough
ed continue with your K pronounced
really just little things like learning
like the fat guy was like oh no no I
don't just like this isn't just I say
the words you said like I have to sell
ideas and reactions and emotions and
rapidly fast epic voice guy page and I
really like the any Austria that where
we just change it up quite a bit mmm-hmm
like happy deathday was one of those
yeah I really like that went into the
spider versus another good recent one
that I really liked that was figuring
out how to integrate all those different
talents in there and that was one where
props to you again Kevin I wish you guys
could just see the moments where one of
us walks into the post and says this is
neat what if we opened a dimensional
portal that flash teases of both the
actors and the carrot and you're just
like uh-huh
oh yeah just full Bruce Willis yeah I
like anything musical that's always fun
Yeah right parody lyrics and they those
are the versions of the songs that I
know it's a little bit of a self but
it's like the versions that we write are
the ones in my head any time also on a
personal level just say Jumanji cos was
the first one I got to like write the
first draft myself so personally it
feels like a monkey the the Robin
Williams G not not not them and yeah and
then like what's the greatest showmen oh
yeah cuz we just had we just pulled
people from the office and gathered them
all in a room and make them sing and
that's the tremors are music I was like
directing them and that was really fun
Jinxy asks why are we still wearing
headphones good don't need them okay we
need to wrap it up so just a couple more
do we have a least favorite Oz trailer I
have one it was for the second Planet of
the Apes like good Planet of the Apes
movie where John Donne or Rhys I always
get the confused where that's the rise
we so clearly have nothing funny to say
about it but it was just like the one
movie that people wanted and was out
that week like it was the one where the
the Gary Oldman where the ape had to two
guns on horseback like riding around
shooting it and like you can tell maybe
three or four times just like that part
was cool I think we've gotten better at
it or just like using movies as an
excuse to talk about other interesting
things if there's not much interesting
going on with the movie but like the
best movies don't make the best honest
trailers that's that's like people
always when they'll only put out like
what
all-time movies we do want to see us do
people always request like great move
like Groundhog Day
there's a lot less to say it's much
easier to do and especially wines that
are like just that are good that are
just entertaining but not because great
ones I think are actually easier than
ones that are just good that was a good
movie yes because the honest take which
we try to do is yeah it's a it's good we
try to just say it like it is yeah I
feel like I can't think of one that I
outright was like yeah I know there's a
lot where we're like okay moving on to
next week like we got it done cool some
were more struggles than others but I
think they always come out yeah I mean I
don't watch him and be like wow we
really drop the books on this one thing
that makes me chuckle
looking back so I'll take that and I'm
told it's time so I hope we've done one
thing that made you chuckle today I saw
one other question will there be an SJ
you today yes we're just gonna keep the
cameras going right now SJ you but thank
you so much for sticking with us this
long for sticking with us through 300
years 250 more 50 to 100 I don't know
little job security let's say I want to
set expectations low so we can always
climb over them is this how I find out
movies we can only make a hundred more
of these now it's going monthly yeah oh
boy all right guys thank you for joining
us Kevin we couldn't be doing what we're
doing how what your ears like thank you
beep Dan Danielle John Bailey of course
all the people who make this happen
thank you and fans like yourselves we'll
see you next week for again something
very wet bye bye
[Music]
you